لقد مروا عبر وادي ظل
الموت
معظمهم ولكن ليس كلهم ​​تمكنوا من الخروج من
الوادي أحياء
لكنهم لم يصابوا بأذى
على هذا الطريق المطل على
معارك باهاموت وسوليداد ، إنه
آمن بما يكفي لإيصال الجرحى
إلى المسعفين
المتناثرين على طول  على الطريق ، نقالة ملطخة بالدماء ، سترة واقية من الرصاص ملطخة بالدماء ،
هذه القوات عادت للتو من
الجبهة ، إنها سوليداد التي أصيبوا بجروح ،
كانوا يواجهون مقاتلي فاغنر ،
يقولون إن هؤلاء المقاتلين كانوا يهاجمون في
موجات ، والآن يعودون إلى
قتال بري أكثر أمانًا رأوه.  كان هناك
جنود نظاميون يقول هذا
الجندي وأمامهم فقط قابلوا
المدانين وهجمات على المخدرات بدون
دروع بدون خوذات بالنسبة لهم الحياة
ليس لها قيمة
في The Killing Fields ،
يستمر القصف دون توقف
للمسعفين ولا راحة
أحيانًا لا تمنحنا قذائف الهاون أي
مساحة للتنفس ، أخبرني مسعف الأناضول أن
لدينا العديد من الضحايا
عندما يأتي القناصة ، ثم هناك
العديد من القتلى والجرحى من
الجنود ينقلون رفيقًا سقطوا من
سيارتهم المصفحة إلى شاحنة
نسمع ظل الموت شكرًا ثقيلًا